salve youtubers benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
lo so lo so in passato un altro mese
dall'ultimo video ma avevo veramente un
sacco di invece un giorno dovevo andare
lì e un giorno mi giro dovevo fare
un'altra cosa è una mi chiama mi devo
devo andare lì e poi devo andare a
quella fila e poi devo andare e poi la
fiera è lavoro e la siete bevuta mi sa
di no ma comunque iniziamo il film che
voglio recensire oggi e boa versus
python un film del 2004 diretto da david
flores force e come avrete capito dal
titolo rientra nella categoria versus
[Musica]
ma bando alle ciance e iniziamo con
questo abominio è giusto mi sono
dimenticato di dirmelo
è una merda il film inizia ad atlantic
city durante un incontro di wrestling
qui facciamo la conoscenza di non mi
ricordo il suo nome perché non me ne
frega nulla in compagnia della sua
ragazza gli arriva una telefonata da
ramon perché ogni persona sudamericana
nei film di serie b si chiama ramon che
gli comunica che il pacco è arrivato ma
c'è un problema il contenuto si è
svegliato e invece di lasciarlo dentro
al camion blindatissimo decidono di
farlo uscire per sparargli un
tranquillante
wow mi chiedo cosa succederà
colpo di scena ma se pensate che questi
non possano essere più stupidi così
guardate cosa succede dopo
[Applauso]
bene
e cioè
[Applauso]
[Musica]
l'osso neanche da dove iniziare a
descrivere questo scempio
prima di tutto perché nessuno sparava
non avevano aperto la porta proprio per
sparargli il tranquillante
secondo perché settare una bomba soli 30
secondi
quanto sei scemo ma soprattutto quante
sono le probabilità che un uomo borso da
un serpente spari un colpo di fucile
proprio sul tizio che ha la bomba no non
voglio neanche pensarci tanto mi
esploderebbe la testa prima che finisce
il film scena dopo vediamo non mi
ricordo il suo nome su un aereo che
festeggia con la sua compagna la
vittoria dell'incontro di prima
oh bene scene di nudo a caso per
attirare i pip ha
quando il telegiornale noi in forma
dell'incidente del camion che
magicamente cori tatto ma non l'abbiamo
visto esplodere poco fa non lo so
arriva la scientifica e vede uno strano
buco in una botola possiamo dedurre che
il serpente è ancora vivo ma ancora mai
avrei specchi aprire loro molto da dire
per questa scena è un [ __ ]
il serpente intanto attacca una centrale
idrica così la polizia è costretta a
chiamare la sua specialista
[Musica]
chiedo scusa questo è un film di
serpenti giganti che lottano tra loro o
una puntata del jersey shore
ed eccola la biologa marina impegnate in
una gara dove bisogna trattenere il
fiato
[Applauso]
[Musica]
questa è la tua reazione per aver visto
un seno sei sicuro che non fosse così
[Musica]
avrebbe più senso viene portata nel
laboratorio dove le viene presentato un
altro biologo che ha un po geneticamente
modificato perché magari allergico ai
gatti che ne so
sì
signore e signori la nostra esperta
in poche parole vogliono usare il boa
per cercare il pitone
intanto non mi ricordo il suo nome mette
in piedi una squadra di cacciatori per
recuperare il pitone e siccome i cliché
non solo mai abbastanza abbiamo quello
figo quello vecchio texano quello
tenebroso che non parla mai e quelli
imbranati
sì è proprio [ __ ] questa scena
assolutamente non ridicola
nel laboratorio intanto vogliono
attaccare una telecamera e un sensore al
boa per monitorarlo nella ricerca
[Musica]
no no no no no no no no no no non
accadrà lo so non accadrà
no mi rifiuto di crederci no no
questo film fa schifo ma non potrà mai
cadere così in basso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
oh mio dio lo ha fatto il film l'ha
fatto è riuscito a partorire la scena
più stupida dell'anno congratulazioni
film hai vinto puoi venire a ritirare il
premio stupido domino film stupido
nel mentre un inviato il suo cameraman
discutono su come fare giornalismo
perché si sa quando uno guarda un film
con un po e un pitone si aspetta un
inviato di il suo cameraman che
discutono di giornalismo
il dottore però non vuole uccidere il
pitone perché secondo lui è immorale
sono sicuro che anche il pitone la pensa
così
[Musica]
già così decide di usare dei
tranquillanti
ricapitolando abbiamo i militari con il
boa e la justice league dei poveri
entrambe a cercare il pitone mentre i
primi lo cercano in una struttura
sotterranea i secondi vagano senza meta
in una foresta è il primo a morire sarà
sarà
fallica
[Musica]
il vecchio texano
grazie a dio i due imbranati cercano di
dare una mano
io
[Musica]
sullo star bene perché non ridete ha già
perché non è divertente e sapete perché
non è divertente perché non è divertente
ma i militari sono ancora peggio
oh mio dio
ok è il duo che doveva dirigere il verso
il pitone si è rivoltato contro di loro
un militare viene attaccato spara terra
ma i suoi colpi rimbalzano colpiscono un
tubo vicino ad un suo compagno che
prende fuoco
esattamente la stessa minchiata di prima
lì non è possibile non è final
destination queste dovrebbero essere
delle morti accidentali ma non lo so ma
sono solo stupide e quando il film non
potrebbe scendere più in basso di così
il bo e il pitone si trovano e iniziano
a fare sesso
non sto scherzando sai cosa buon per voi
almeno voi riuscite a divertirvi in
mezzo a questa montagna di vomito
finalmente i due gruppi si incontrano e
il figo colpisce per sbaglio il capo dei
militari
[Applauso]
[Musica]
subito prima di essere pappato dal
pitone
si chiama karma amico mio quando ad un
certo punto vengono inondati da un muro
d'acqua
[Musica]
no non chiedete a me non ne ho idea
non mi ricordo il suo nome la ragazza
trovano delle uova nei rompono una e
fanno incazzare il boa che uccide il
tenebroso mangiandone metà figata e
soffoca la ragazza i due biologi
scappano dal pitone nuotando sott'acqua
e fuggono a gambe levate incontrano non
mi ricordo suo nome e vengono raggiunti
dai militari scoprono che il pitone sta
portando via le uova del bo ha ferito
non mi ricordo il suo nome nel frattempo
ruba indisturbato un blindato nulla di
strano
c'erano soltanto 400 mila soldati che lo
stavano sorvegliando o guardaci di nuovo
il jersey shore in realtà è una festa a
pochi isolati dal campo militare dove il
nostro pitone decide di imbucarsi
arrivano i soldati con i due biologi e
non mi ricordo suo nome con un
lanciafiamme
riusciranno i nostri eroi a far finire
questo film di merda non mi ricordo il
suo nome abbrustolisce il pitone come
una fiammata e poi attacca anche i
biologi e militari domanda perché
non so che cazzo sto facendo ma fa figo
questa scena mi ha fatto morire dalle
risate un soldato e atterra in fiamme un
tizio a caso cerca di spegnerlo con uno
straccio non ci riesce tenda di
scavalcarlo e il prende fuoco
ma quanto sei scemo te lo meriti ma il
pitone è ancora vivo
eppure il boa
e cala è impazzito di nuovo ma qualcuno
lo fermi prima che si trasformi in duke
nukem è gravoso stile grazie
i due serpentoni lo dilaniano senza
pietà
alleluia e finalmente iniziano a lottare
era da un'ora e mezza che stava
aspettando questo momento
finiscono nella metropolitana e se le
danno di santa ragione
no non ti azzardare seri non ci provare
ti uccido
[Musica]
no stronzo stronzo stronzo di un film ti
odio come ti odio il biologo ucci del
boa elettrificando gli sensori e il
pitone viene investito una schifo di ore
e mezza per aspettare questo momento è
tutto finisce così in 5 secondi
almeno sono stati coerenti una tristezza
di finale per una tristezza di film
[Musica]
quindi questo era muoversi spy phone ma
non si sono dimenticati di una cosa il
titolo dice versus lo scontro tra i due
serpenti e durato cinque secondi
dovrebbe essere un nuovo record mondiale
come un film non riesce a rispettare le
anche il proprio titolo è morto in
partenza bastogi o fatevene un regalo
evitatelo io come al solito vi ringrazio
tutti gli scritti di tutti i commenti di
tutti i complimenti che mi fate e vado
un attimo a vomitare in bagno